on this point of the hollow attacks on
Trump why I think Trump is actually
stronger in 2024 than he was in 2020 is
because it's for it's for one of the
reasons that some people consider Trump
weaker but I think it's actually an
advantage for a a wild eccentric
candidate like Trump which is in a way
he's kind of yesterday's news here is
typical liberal interview liberal
interviewer Hollywood star being
interviewed barest risean saying if
Trump is elected she can't live in the
country you've known of you've known and
supported a lot of political figures you
friends with the clintons I'm not going
to get into you dating Pierre Trudeau
but you have politicians in more than
one country shall we say what do you
make of the political climate of the
United States now bad well I like Biden
MH I like Biden I think he's done a good
job I think he's
compassionate he's smart he support
reports the right things how do you feel
about the Spectre of a second Trump
Administration I will
move I can't live in this country if
that's if he became president but where
would you go where would you go if
probably to England MH I like
England England is very nice but she's
serious she's not telling a joke here I
would move I would move if Trump became
president I couldn't live in this
country
if Trump became
president except you did well that's
true I
did yeah you lived here for four years
when Trump was pres yeah that's true I
did I I did and it was fine right you're
totally fine you're okay you're alive
you're you th you probably made even
more money than you previously had and
everything was fine well yeah but I
couldn't do it
again this is why I think the the
reelect especially with this
intermediate period uh where Biden has
been president president where
everything's gone to pot I think it puts
Trump in a stronger position because it
it
defangs the the attacks what are the
attacks on Trump that work
now he's Hitler and he's going to kill
everyone well he didn't do that he is
going to start World War I actually no
Biden's starting World War II Don Donald
Trump was the best foreign policy
president in my lifetime he was the most
most peaceful president I I've ever seen
in my whole life uh well well okay Trump
fine when he's president but he won't
leave office yeah he did though and he
didn't want to and you rigged the
election but he left
anyway well we just it will the country
will be unlivable for the liberal Elites
the liberal Elites were fine you all
threatened to leave and then he got
elected and you stayed and you were fine
and now you're just doing this it's just
so exhausting it's so silly because it's
just the same you're like robots you
know it's the same nonsense over and
over
again but it this time you look even
more ridiculous because you're you've
either proven yourselves to be
Hypocrites and proven yourselves to be
unserious or you've proven your warnings
to be specious and ridiculous right now
go to bulletproof everyone.com use code
nolles bulletproof everyone is
revolutionizing everyday safety with
their exclusive line of bulletproof
clothing imagine your favorite jacket
your favorite hoodie with added
bulletproof protection that is what
Bulletproof everyone offers everyday
clothing with an extraordinary twist
these clothes are designed to look and
feel just like your usual wardrobe items
but with a hidden layer of safety the
ultimate blend of fashion and function
you can say goodbye to the bulkiness of
regular soft armor it is so lightweight
comfortable you will forget that you are
wearing anything at all despite how thin
and light they are these clothes provide
a robust defense against various threats
with their 3A option capable of stopping
up to a 44 magnum that is their top tier
protection in a Sleek package best part
they're as easy to care for as your
regular clothes wear wash repeat no
special handling required they even
offer free tailoring with every single
order bulletproof everyone sent us a
custom jacket and check this
out this is not only one of the
backpacks that they sent me this is the
same backpack that you will get for free
with any purchase of clothing I travel a
lot so it's nice to have peace of mind
that I'm always protected stay protected
without sacrificing style or Comfort
bulletproof everyone is not just
changing clothing they're changing the
game in personal safety right now our
listeners can get 10% off plus a free
bulletproof backpack with the purchase
of any bulletproof clothing just use
code NES at checkout at bulletproof
everyone.com bulletproof everyone.com
promo code nolles right now text nolles
to 200 300 for most homeowners window
replacement is not something they've
done before for many others it is not
something they want to do it's something
they have to do have you put off
replacing the windows in your home
because it's too expensive well I've got
great news you can now get a free inhome
window consultation and a free quote
from Renewal by Anderson Renewal by
Anderson's signature service is
committed to giving you the best
customer experience possible supported
by the best people in the industry in
fact I know this because one of my
cousins works for Renewal by Anderson
and has actually for years before they
came on the show as an Advertiser I then
got an email from a carpenter totally
unsolicited who said Michael I heard you
talk about Renewal by Anderson they are
absolutely the greatest when I work on a
home I can tell right away when Renewal
by Anderson has done the windows because
they are top quality they're offering a
free inhome or virtual consultation on
durable quality affordable windows or
patio doors for zero down zero payment
zero interest for a year text nlls to
200 300 for your free consultation save
375 bucks off every window 750 bucks off
every door these savings will not last
long be sure to check it out text Nes to
200 300 that is nolles to 200 300
texting privacy policy in terms of
conditions posted at text plan. us
texting roles for recurring automated
text marketing messages message and data
rates may apply reply stop to opt out go
to windowappointment now.com for full
offer
details which is why by the way you now
seeing the field winow in the race and
you're seeing the endorsements begin to
coales around Trump whether you like
Trump whether you hate Trump there's a
reason why in Florida a number of people
who had previously endorsed as santis
are now endorsing Trump certain people
are are who had been on the fence are
still endorsing people like Dan santis
potentially like Haley I'm thinking of
Kim Reynolds that was a big one in Iowa
the the governor of Iowa but generally
the movement seems to be for
endorsements into the Trump Camp because
even if the people endorsing Trump right
now don't even like Trump that much even
if they had previously endorsed Ronda
Sanz and they ran they ran against Trump
they realize that it just looks like the
guy is going to be the nominee and
they're going to get on the winning team
this is including the new Speaker of the
House Mike Johnson as far as I know you
have not endorsed the former president
yet uh for 2024 and this is everybody's
watching this show right now this if
you're going to do that this would be a
great great time to do it Mr Speaker you
ready I I have done it yeah I I have I
have endorsed him wholeheartedly um look
I was uh one of the closest allies that
President Trump had in Congress he had a
phenomenal first term those first two
years as you all know we brought about
the greatest economic numbers in the
history of the world not just the
country because his policies worked and
I'm I'm all in for president Trump I I
expect he'll be our nominee yeah and and
he's going to win it and we have to make
Biden a one-term presid presid we have
to do that now I don't mean to insinuate
here that Mike Johnson is only endorsing
Trump because the writing is on the wall
I don't think that's the case I think he
was a trump supporter before and I I
there's no reason to believe he's not
totally sincere and Earnest
here but that's a big endorsement he
didn't have to endorse this
early speaker of the house is a big
endorsement and there are a lot of other
people who are endorsing I think in a
less sincere way but simply because they
see that the writing is on the wall and
in part this is because Trump made a bet
the BET was I think the nominations
locked up I'm not even going to show up
to the debates that could have backfired
on him and the voters could have said
hey
man you you're disrespecting us we want
you to come make your case you need to
earn our vote that's what Haley and
DeSantis and the other Republicans
argued and it just doesn't seem to have
worked so with the writing on the wall
you can expect more endorsements and you
can expect a more concerted strategy
from the Democrats to call Trump Hitler
even more loudly and with even more of a
serious face on it and you can expect
more celebrities to threaten to leave
the country and you can expect more uh
liberals to sacrifice their children and
their property to Nature gods and you
you can just expect more of the same
that we've seen for years and frankly
even Millennia man what a great clip
that was now hey hey hold
up ring that Bell subscribe to the
Michael nolles YouTube channel we'll see
you next time